wir erzählen ihnen jetzt von einer ganz
besonderen geschichte die mut macht von
einem mann der mut macht denn er hat
zunächst ein schweres schicksal erleiden
müssen es ging nicht mehr anders bei ihm
das bein des 31 jährigen musste nämlich
amputiert werden sie sehen hier eine
amputation war nicht mehr zu verhindern
die diagnose bei ihm krebs im rechten
knöchel das ist schicksal von daniel
döhring aus buer in nord-westfalen
feuerwehrmann mit leib und seele nur wie
kann er mit dieser einschränkung
weiterhin als feuerwehrmann arbeiten wir
haben ihnen vier jahre nach seiner
amputation getroffen
die amputation war unvermeidlich so
aggressiv weil der krebs in seinem
knöchel kann ich noch feuerwehrmann sein
ohne meinen unterschenkel fragte sich
daniel koring aus buer vier jahre später
weiß er er kann mir bedeutet die arbeit
bei der feuerwehr viel es ist
abwechslung es ist hochspannung es ist
kritisch wir sind oft herausgefordert
und es ist auch vor allem familie es war
ein montag der dreizehnter november 2017
an diesem tag amputierten ärzte an der
uniklinik münster den rechten
unterschenkel von daniel koring er war
gerade 31
zunächst einmal war da einfach nur leere
ich habe keinen richtigen gedanken
fassen können da gehen einem später erst
viele fragen durch den kopf wie es denn
weitergeht wie es mit der arbeit
weitergeht wie es mit autofahren
weitergeht so ganz einfache sachen die
eigentlich selbstverständlich sind aber
natürlich halt auch wie geht es bei der
feuerwehr weiter und kann ich überhaupt
wieder zur feuerwehr gehen daniel koring
entschied sich fürs leben und gegen sein
rechtes bein
obwohl er um seine große leidenschaft
bangen musste der freiwilligen feuerwehr
ich bin mit elf jahren in die
jugendfeuerwehr eingetreten für mich
waren es damals große rote autos mit
blaulicht wie das für viele kinder so
ist und mich hat diese faszination
einfach gepackt und ich bin auch dabei
geblieben so dass ich jetzt zum august
dieses jahres dann 25 jahre dann aktives
mitglied einer feuerwehr bin nach der
amputation und anschließend der
chemotherapie trainierte er hat für
seine traum lernte mit der prothese
wieder zulaufen und auto zu fahren der
ehemalige hobbyfußballer wollte erneut
mit den kameraden zu einsätzen fahren
die motivation hierhin wieder zurück zu
kommen war für mich somit eine die
größten eine der größten tatsächlich
dadurch dass man diese kameradschaft hat
die kameradschaft ist mehr wie
kameradschaft es ist familie und man hat
natürlich lust mit dem kameraden wieder
zusammen auf dem einsatzfahrzeug raus zu
fahren und den bürgern wieder zu helfen
aber genau dann weiß man wenn man selber
hilfe gebraucht hat wie wichtig es ist
dass leute vorbeikommen und halt auch
entsprechende helfen seine kameraden und
freunde ließen ihn gerade wegen der
schicksals diagnose nie im stich ging
mit daniel durch dick und dünn ich weiß
dass noch als daniel die diagnose
bekommen hat als sie aus dem krankenhaus
wieder kamen waren wir glaube ich seine
erste anlaufstelle wenn ich das noch
richtig weiß stand bei uns vor der tür
war ziemlich aufgelöst hat uns dann von
der diagnose berichtet und ja das hat
auch mich letztendlich ziemlich
aufgewühlt
ich kann gut und gerne sagen dass ich
sicherlich auch eine träne im knopfloch
hatte und auch jetzt würde mich das noch
auch wenn ich darüber nachdenke weil man
eben eng befreundet ist und das ist so
als würde man selbst die diagnose
bekommen ja es unheimlich schönen liegen
dann wieder im dienst zu sehen war ja
auch letztendlich unser ziel dass wir
gesagt haben
wenn dann alles überstanden ist gehen
wir direkt wieder weitermachen da weiter
wo wir vorher aufgehört haben und
ja man freut sich schon wenn man dann
beim ersten einsatz sieht dass daniel
wieder mit dem feuerwehrhaus steht das
war schon echt toller moment heute ist
daniel koring stellvertretender
brandmeister der ortsfeuerwehr buer wenn
er auf sein bein verloren hat aber
bestimmt nicht den willen zur
aufopferung und den mut mit den
kameraden durchs feuer zu gehen
und nun ist er uns zugeschaltet daniel
kuhring stellvertretender brandmeister
der ortsfeuerwehr ein stadtteil von
gelsenkirchen dort brühe ist herr koch
in wie geht's ihnen
ja mir geht es soweit ganz gut danke
was hat dieser schicksalsschlag und die
prothese wie sehr hat das ihr leben
verändert
ja der schicksalsschlag hat mich in
meiner persönlichkeit in verändert in
dem sinne dass ich noch motivierter noch
fröhlicher durchs leben gehe auch wenn
das als widerspruch sich anhört aber
man hat eben noch mehr mut gefasst
weiterzuleben und weiterleben zu dürfen
hatten sie irgendwann mal den gedanken
nach der amputation das ist das mit der
feuerwehr gewesen ist dass sie das sein
lassen müssen
ich habe nie daran gedacht mit der
feuerwehr aufzuhören im gegenteil das
war sogar mit der größte anreiz das
ganze so zu überstehen und halt zu
kämpfen dafür dass ich eben wieder zur
feuerwehr gehen kann
das war das schwierigste in der phase
was hat ihnen am meisten mut gemacht in
dieser zeit
also mir hat ganz viel mut gemacht dass
alle meine freunde meine ganze familie
alle haben zu mir gehalten haben mich
auch motiviert haben selber mal gesagt
das ist ganz ganz stark ist wie ich
damit umgehe und ja ich habe mich selber
jeden tag wieder motiviert und mein
umfeld wie gesagt wieder arbeiten zu
können wieder zu verdienen zu können das
war halt einfach motivation grund genug
so viel kämpfen zu können